un duel donald trump versus joe biden
jusqu'à présent la course à la maison
blanche se limitait à une confrontation
entre ces deux hommes
mais le 4 juillet dernier en tweets a
quelque peu perturbé le cours de la
campagne présidentielle américaine un
tweet signé kanye west nous devons
maintenant accomplir la promesse de
l'amérique en ayant confiance en dieu en
unifiant nos visions et en construisant
notre avenir
je suis candidat à la présidence des
états unis pour le moment le rappeur
hommes d'affaires et milliardaire de 43
ans n'a pas fourni davantage de détails
sur ses intentions
impossible donc de savoir s'il s'agit
d'une plaisanterie ou d'une réelle
ambition toujours est il que kanye west
a déjà reçu quelques soutiens et
notamment celui d'ellen masquer le
patron de tesla aux 36 millions
d'abonnés sur twitter
mais dans les rues de new york les
réactions sont beaucoup plus mitigées
c'est de la folie c'est une idée folle
je veux dire ce pays est déjà foutu pour
commencer a ajouté cela cette idée et
nous serons complètement perdu je pense
que c'est une super idée parce que je
pense qu'il est temps pour les états
unis de se débarrasser de trump nous
sommes fatigués de lui nous ne voulons
pas de trump pour président vous ne
pouvez pas donner un président en
seulement quatre ans pour diriger un
pays il a besoin de plus et tout ça pour
vous dire que je donne un peu ma faveur
à trump en le traitant correctement il a
besoin de quatre ans supplémentaires
pour voir ce qu'il pourrait faire c'est
un bon type et ce n'est pas la première
fois que l'artiste évoque cette ambition
présidentielle en 2015 à la cérémonie
des mtv video awards kanye west avait
déjà 2020 en tête et puis plus récemment
en 2010 neuf lors d'une interview dans
beats one show une émission d'appels
musique l'homme avait affirmé qu'il
serait un jour à la tête du pays
il viendra un temps où je serai le
président des états unis et je me
souviendrai de tout fondateur qui n'aura
pas été capables de comprendre
culturellement ce que nous faisons il
s'agit d'idées et mon frère de nouvelles
idées des gens avec des idées des gens
qui croient à la vérité et oui comme
vous l'avez probablement deviné à ce
moment là j'ai décidé en 2020
de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle on peut aussi citer l'une
des paroles de son titre fact en 2020 je
gagnerai l'élection une candidature qui
selon certains analystes n'apportera
rien d'autre qu'une division des votes
côté démocrate
qu'est-ce qu'a kanye west à nous offrir
rien il ne proposera rien de plus
tout ce qu'il fera c'est diviser les
votes des démocrates les gens côté
conservateurs républicains eux ne
voteront pas pour kanye west il pourrait
peut-être attirer les voix des jeunes
mais ce vote je n'a jamais à mon avis et
n'aura jamais sans doute une grande
influence sur les élections
ce dans mon groupe d'âge des 40 ans et
plus n'iront pas voter pour kanye west
et ses dix sans animosité envers lui
c'est juste leur regard sur ce qu'il
pourra réellement accomplir mais kanye
west peut-il réellement devenir le 46e
président des états unis peu probable
premièrement parce qu'ils ne possèdent
l'investiture d'aucun parti il faudrait
donc il se présente en candidat
indépendant
l'histoire des états unis nous a montré
qu'un candidat ni républicain ni
démocrate n'avait aucune chance
d'accéder à la victoire
et puis deuxièmement le temps presse
l'élection et dans quatre mois ce qui
laisse peu de marge aux rappeurs pour
remplir toutes les formalités
administratives afin d'entrer dans la
course si 2020 semble quasiment joué
pour kanye west l'artiste pourrait
reporter son ambition à 2024 l'homme a
toujours affiché son soutien à donald
trump et il n'est pas impossible qu'ils
entendent briguer l'investiture
républicaine dans avec quatre ans autre
interrogation et si cette candidature
cash est plutôt un bon coup de com
l'artiste a en effet sorti le 30 juin
dernier soit quatre jours avant son
tweet un single qui annonce l'arrivée de
son nouvel album god scontri la question
mérite d'être posée